>>In a few days the world leaders are gathering
in Davos at the World
Economic Forum to discuss how to improve the
state of the world.
My name is Loic Le Meur, and I'm going to
moderate the social
networking panel of Davos.
All the main social network leaders will be
there.
Twitter, MySpace, Ning, Facebook, LinkedIn,
all of them.
You can participate in the debate by asking
a question which we will
show during the conversation in front of all
those world leaders.
Here's how you do it: You go to YouTube.com/Davos,
you press submit a
question button, and then you can ask a question
or leave a comment.
Here's a question: Has the rise of social
network improved society?
The videos with the highest number of votes
will be displayed in front
of the world leaders and we will discuss it.
So go ahead do it now.